to help celebrate our 11 years of shows
at tbs we're putting together montages
of some of our favorite show highlights
we've had a lot of amazing guests over
the years take a look
i want to do something better than a
selfie so i did
a selfishly but i let him be the star of
the selfish
first sofashi ever with two celebrities
in it there we are
i like you i like you too
i mean i think you're good thank you yes
thank you very much
there's different i think now you're
hosting the 2015 mtv movie awards
that is this weekend sunday sunday and i
hosted that thing last year and it is
different than all of the other award
shows
it is yes yeah they asked me they said
they wanted to like make it funny again
yeah and uh oh
no do you go in the water or the ocean a
lot are you because some people hate the
ocean oh i like the ocean you
i do i like the ocean very much yeah
that's great you must
do you float a lot in the ocean
sure what do you think
it might be that cast iron heart
when i was on stage i moved the stool
next to me just slightly and it made
this weird noise
and it caused the entire audience to
laugh collectively
i was like oh that's all you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i feel needed maybe some of you aren't
into it
i noticed that uh you drive the tesla
and uh
very popular car out here in los angeles
an electric car electric car yeah
it's in the shop now we're having a gas
engine put in it
nice nothing better than ronald reagan's
swearing
really what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
there's nothing greater in all of comedy
the only thing better goes way back is
jimmy stewart's swearing oh yeah
yeah well how you doing yeah well pretty
good how are you doing
wow well [ __ ] you
you have a bird on your uh
on your shoulder
[Laughter]
you know conan um here's the deal i'm
i'm happy to come on your show
and i'm i'm happy to talk about the
movie
uh get hard i'm happy to talk about you
know anything
but i don't want to talk about my
personal life okay
um you're out there with shaq
does he try and trash you does he try
and get inside your head what's it like
at this point no
not at all not at all i mean does he say
anything to you
if he did i wouldn't understand him
anyway
which one which one do you want i want
the jeep you want the pink jeep all
right
we're gonna pull these with ropes
[Applause]
so we play basketball we got to get back
to the movie set
shaq has to take a shower
so everyone's like all right we'll see
you later shag in my head i'm like
i gotta see shaq's penis
[Laughter]
i mean for historical reasons yeah it's
not not a gay thing it's just like
got to see that yeah i'm walking
backwards
doing my routine getting closer to the
shower and then i turn around
and i go all right i'm going to see
shaq's thing right now
his bodyguard is there and his bodyguard
is just so strong and
big and like this thick neck
bald head and this one eyes looking at
me with this one eye
so i said sorry i was just
trying to see shaq's penis so i see shaq
later on the set
and i was like i guarantee that guy
ratted me out so i said
jack uh sorry about that before with the
with your security guard and he goes i
don't got a security guard that was my
dick
i suggested that we do some sort of uh
you know choreographed stunt thing and
your
but your producer said that you would
not be into that no he's not supposed to
just unilaterally say no we don't do
they supposed to ask me
frank get out here yeah why didn't you
tell me about this
i didn't think it was a good idea well
let me just
you didn't think it was a a good idea
[Applause]
i actually decided to bring a backup
guest
tonight i'm sorry i've been doing this a
long time i've never heard of anyone
bringing a backup guest
i i just think it would make you know it
would make me feel a bit better because
i don't know how this is going to go
so that way if it's if i'm it's not
working or my story's not good
you you have the ability to switch over
to another guest
susan do you want to come out now or
thanks how did you get susan sarandon to
come
out here how did you do that
i got her through my booker i guess i
have a better booker than you
my whole life kind of grew up in this
whole thing i was like i don't like
banks i think they're stealing our money
and then i worked at a bank and i was
like oh i was right
okay well glad you didn't mention the
name of the bank yeah what could be a
bank
wow that's a commercial we're not
getting um
you still got those folgers people
though uh oh don't get me started on
folks
shout out got the word out of you
functions
best part of waking up my ass
i saw photos of you and your good friend
mr jason bateman
hanging out together paparazzi photos
and uh these are real
and i think you should probably explain
oh there you go that's nice yeah
sometimes the the paparazzi guys they
ride around on bikes and
they run they ride ahead of you and then
they get to the end of the block and
they start snapping
pics and they want to get you like you
know picking your nose or whatever
and i said the baby and i said you know
let's let's have
fun at their expense and just grabbed
his hand and i feel like his internal
monologue was
finally um
by the way you can tell by the photo i'm
the top
guys come on what what is it andy why
don't you just settle it with a guitar
[Music]
[Applause]
off
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
oh my god
sorry
you